when scientists on the Forefront find
something they don't understand this is
an exciting day it's not a day to worry
it's like oh my gosh this doesn't fit
let's find out why yeah but we're not
doing the whole painting over I sort of
envisaging just Wendy just furious
punching through a straw boater I'm not
just stamping on the floor every time
news telescope fighting has come through
when we go to school when you learn
science there's you know you're given a
problem and then you can look up the
answer in the back of the book and with
the universe there's no back of the book
to look up the answers you know the
closest thing we have to the back of the
book yeah you show it to a colleague and
then does it look right to you not you
messed up Wendy you forgot to carry the
two and if they're doing their job it is
their obligation to find out where we
messed up yes they're not our friend if
they say oh let's not tell her you know